hey [ __ ] yo yes before we get started
we want to announce that we have a
highlights channel like on my cheeks
yeah so if you want bite-sized hey [ __ ]
highlights just click on the link in the
description or on screen right now for
our new hey [ __ ] highlights Channel
[Applause]
right this is a second channel because
we need more money alright go subscribe
and watch it [ __ ] man these are easy
clips to share with your friends if
they're like what is this podcast that
you're all about send them these little
clips it's way easier to get them into
it somebody that's so best oh can I have
a troll clip remember like when I first
when I screamed up let's unbox anything
you label it something else like family
friendly and then have them send it to
random people you're welcome [ __ ] yeah
go subscribe now on to the episode hello
welcome back to hey [ __ ] podcast we
missed you finish we're gonna start off
by taking a roll call who's here let's
start over on that side all right we're
starting on this side I'm Jessica hi
thanks for listening and it's Jessica
joining us today
this is TIFF this is Nikki and hi I'm
Gina I wish I was a Doppler effect so
you can tell that it went from left to
right so what do we got today maybe
Jessica is here because she's gonna help
us out with these topics which are self
esteem self confidence and self care oh
well Jessica pretends to have those and
just has them not at all
is there to fight for Jess so I'm
representing for all you girls we love
self-esteem because though we're right
here yeah
they ever learn yeah and did you know I
can't wait from Eugenia because you say
you always have I feel like I'm I'm
gonna be a very boring speaker in this
one and I'll tell you why later good I
think you bein late but we were talking
before the topic before we started
recording about how self esteem and self
confident or confidence are two
different things yeah I didn't know that
yeah different thing yeah so self esteem
refers to how you feel about yourself
overall like how like how you like if
you think that you're bad person or not
but self confidence is more about how
secure you are with your skills so a
person could be really confident about
say like doing accounting you know yeah
you went to school for accounting you
went to school for whatever your major
was you're very confident in that skill
set but you have very low self esteem as
a person yeah okay yeah I do see myself
as not a very intelligent person is that
a bad self yeah I think you're a very
emotionally intelligent - yeah you are
very intelligent if you always put
yourself down and color yourself slow
and I know it's kind of like a running
joke sometimes but but you're really
quick like if I if someone makes a pun
like I don't know if I've made it like
wordplay thing you're the only one that
catches it builds up your self-esteem
but you're very confident in like all
the stuff that you do to prepare for
work right like you know your skills you
know how much time you need to prepare
oh yeah I guess like with self-esteem
and self-confidence it's not like a
blanket thing because for me it's
definitely like certain areas I'm like
high self esteem they're low self esteem
there and their confidence yeah it's
interesting cuz I didn't know that there
were two separate things like you
literally just taught me something name
cool you guys too but like yeah self
esteem is something that like other
people can kind of tear you down and you
you're like oh yeah I do suck and you
get like down really easily because of
that even in the self confidence to
write if someone tells you you're not
good at something that you were
confident in with that with that apply
you could definitely affect your self
confidence let's say you thought you're
gonna do a killer job
at a speech and you fumble through your
words and you couldn't remember what you
were saying and then that does affect
your confidence in doing a speech in the
future but it can also be a good like
thing for you to work on you know and
help you grow so I mean it's all I feel
like it's always like this and an
undulating type of and it's crazier
they're younger you are - yeah Louis why
so many people and things around you
yeah the media and TV I don't know yeah
I don't know how anyone under the age of
25 has any self esteem like how do they
and if they do they're like amazing
because I'm like I don't know any girls
that I was you know friends with below
the age of 25 that had super strong
self-confidence super strong self-esteem
everyone was just like oh my god I don't
know where my titties too small though I
don't know you know the movie Mean Girls
remember how everyone walks up to the
mirror and everyone's like oh my
shoulders are too wide for Zuri and then
she's like I guess I have to fit in uh
my breaths things in the morning so just
you just always felt like you had a
lower self-esteem like oh for sure I
think it came from a young young eh yeah
yeah super young age I'm sure it came
from just like parental issues and like
my upbringing was really bad or whatever
so it started there but I don't no one
in my life really taught me how to have
good self-esteem or to feel good about
myself I feel like most of the people I
was surrounded by also didn't really
have high self esteem or high self
confidence so like where does someone
get that if they're not if it's not
instilled in them you know what I have
recently learned I think this was Steve
telling me or Joe I forgot because we
recently had a conversation about this
and they were saying that when you have
parent like parental issues like
especially in a case of divorce like
when your parents divorce when you're
really young and one parent is talking
bad about the other parent then because
you are a product of that parent that
they're talking bad about you
immediately connect yourself to start to
absorb it exactly so then your if you're
let's say if your mom's talking [ __ ]
about your dad then your dad it's like a
such a horrible person and you
subconsciously start thinking about
yourself as that horrible person because
you have a piece of them as well mmm I
was like whoa light bulb just turned on
in my head
because that's definitely where I
started having a lower self-esteem and
lower confidence when my parents
divorced and my parents definitely
attacked each other with you in the
middle like I was definitely used as a
weapon
that's so unhealthy I hate when parents
see that's like dude put your kid first
like you're [ __ ] exact should never
ever cross over to their life ever that
was one of the like number one most
important things for me when Isaac and
his dad when we split up I told him like
listen you will forever have your place
in his life I will never talk bad about
your never ever standing between you and
your son cuz I was that kid and I will
never do that into my own son yeah I was
actually on Facebook yesterday there's a
couple that I know that's breaking up
they're Mary and they have a kid because
he cheated and she walked in on him and
whoa she posted a video of her with the
daughter and she was like oh um saying
what you just asked mommy and then the
girls like Oh mommy why are you crying
I'm like dude to [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
like that
yeah cheated on you but don't do you
adults
yeah it's so [ __ ] tacky dude like I'm
not gonna say [ __ ] to you cuz it's your
own [ __ ] issue of leche it was just
so gross and everyone's commenting like
oh my god you know this must hurt her so
much it's like the thing is she's not
even supposed to [ __ ] yeah yeah all this
stuff sticks with you like really like
examine yourself and really do a deep
dive in like why do I feel this way when
people say this and yeah it all stems
back somewhere from your childhood so
Jeana growing up like having a higher
self-esteem where did where do you think
like that kind of came from were you
aware your parents just always like hey
good job with everything no actually I
grew up with the opposite I didn't grow
up with my parents I grew up with my
like grandparents and aunts and uncles
and I think well it came from it was I
got the [ __ ] beat out of me when I was a
kid oh my god so when I grew up I was
like dude if I can handle that I can
handle whatever the [ __ ] it was weird
yeah it's really weird because it's like
yeah I'm going through this but remember
that one time when I got the [ __ ] beat
out of me I'm good so you had like the
worst [ __ ] to compare things yeah so
you're like well this isn't that bad so
I'm doing pretty good
yeah I'm know pretty all right I think
the one thing that really stuck to me
was when my
mom told me she's like no matter what
you're going through don't bother
staying up at night crying about it
because you can't do anything about it
at 2:00 in the morning just get some
sleep and deal with it the next day and
so that's why I don't dwell on things I
don't dwell on what people say about me
and stuff um I don't know like when I
was younger maybe teenage years my
self-esteem wasn't like SuperDuper high
but I already had like the I don't
really give a [ __ ]
personality you know like it you know
that's what I was going for in high
school like for instance like everyone
in high school knew who I was but I
never hung out with them because the
girls were scared of me because I was
like this goth kid they carried a knife
to school right and then I quickly
started thinking like well I mean yeah
these people might say these things
about me but the golden rule is when I'm
on my deathbed these people aren't gonna
be there so who gives a [ __ ] that's so
true yeah you know like yeah talk [ __ ]
about me on YouTube comments or whatever
but when I'm dying or like even during
my happiest days in my wedding day
you're not gonna be there you don't
matter like yeah you're not in my circle
yeah and if I really want to go dark
with it like if you talk [ __ ] about me
like if like you say it's like a random
comment like you met her so little in my
life that if you died tomorrow I
wouldn't know and I wouldn't give a [ __ ]
about you
yeah so none of those opinions ever
mattered to me and one of my golden
rules is no matter what [ __ ] you say
about me my bank account will not lower
it won't be yeah you can say all this
[ __ ] and I'll just look at my bank
coming yeah that's right she's like if
you're not paying my rent you can't tell
me [ __ ] exactly yeah I mean with that
being said don't go to your boss and
calm a [ __ ] because your bank
account will be affected that's such a
good attitude to have I think for me
when I was a kid kid I had pretty high
self-esteem and I felt because I always
tested above average with academics and
stuff I was in like I learned to read
when I was three and it was always
really yeah like my mom would be like
show the way you can do and like I'd
always you know it was impressive to
adults so I always had like this very
high self esteem and high confidence but
then when I got into school like public
school like elementary school I thought
oh like obviously everyone's gonna wanna
be my friend and like this popular girl
really hated me and she wouldn't let
anyone be my friend or
and if anyone was my friend they weren't
invited to her birthday parties now
looking back it was probably jealousy
but but at the time as a kid I was like
oh my god no one wants to be my friend
and I started just doubting everything
about myself and it like it really just
like caused me to lose all that because
all the things that I thought I was good
at or was confident in it now was a
negative like I was getting straight A's
and then people were calling me a nerd
and so I was trying to like not look
smart or like try to like act dumber you
know and then like I don't know things
that like skills that I was confident in
I thought like I took ballet but the
reason my mom put me in ballet classes
was because I was pigeon-toed she was
trying to correct that and pigeon-toed
for those of you don't know your feet
are angled all the way in and so I
walked really funny but I didn't know
about it and so I thought I was like a
good dancer because I'd been taking all
these classes and then all those kids at
school were making fun of me for the way
that I walk and like that I like look
really stupid and all this stuff and
then I got really in my head and so it
was it was kind of that kind of route of
you know starting with high self esteem
going really really low feeling super
depressed when I was in high school and
then by the end of that I did stand-up
comedy because I got to that point of
like bucket like if no one's gonna hang
out with me or be my friend anyway like
I still think there's stuff that I have
to offer and like I still make myself
laugh I would like make myself laugh on
internet forums like that's how I got
involved like the M&M yeah like I feel
like if you like if I didn't learn how
to laugh at myself I would kill myself
by now yeah really gotta learn how to
laugh at yourself and just take things
in stride it was kind of that thing
where I got to say all the [ __ ] that was
stupid about myself yeah first like in
the actor phone
crowd of people and make fun of my own
self and make jokes about it and and
that was super therapeutic for me where
it started boosting my self-esteem back
up like okay I know how to make people
laugh I guess like you can't make fun
like I take the power away from you when
I make fun of myself like you can't pick
on me for something that I'm already
laughing about myself it doesn't work
anymore that takes the power away from
him you know and that's the ID but I
have a thing about that I wonder though
because I've been
self-deprecating person for a long time
too but then I feel like I fulfill not
only yeah not only am i protecting
myself and shielding myself but I'm also
I really believe truly that if you say
it enough yeah and you start to believe
and her voice is very power really well
yeah all right just before we go any
further okay you have a special sponsor
that we need to talk about how special
our special sponsor is for my special
place in my stomach I love it when I say
that a guy you should fill me up from
the inside this is actually what I meant
so shout out the door - hey what's up
ships if you want to make a girl happy
order her something from door - they
connect you to your favorite restaurants
all over the city you can order from
your local - goes sorry
go - way to go or choose from your
favorite chains like Chipotle Wendy's
McDonald's chick-fil-a chick-fil-a is my
personal favorite they connect you with
door to door delivery in over 3,300
cities all 50 states and canada even
canada canada maple syrup to my house
nope yeah so right now our listeners can
get five dollars off their first order
of $15 or more when you download the
door - app and enter promo code hey girl
hey girl that's five dollars off your
first order being downloaded or - out
from the App Store and enter promo code
hey girl h e-- y GI RL again that's
promo code hey girl for five dollars off
your first order from door - yes yes
yeah going back to that inner voice
though it's so freakin powerful and I
realized that my inner voice was evil Oh
evil where it's like nah [ __ ] you're
having a good day no you're not what
about that thing that happened to you
twelve years ago like yeah it's it's
yeah my inner voices yeah and we we are
the stories that we tell ourselves so if
you're constantly telling yourself
you're a bad person or you suck at
everything and like you don't have
anything happening happy for it then you
really believe it because it's kind of
like you're your own parent telling you
that
and then that's why comments affect you
a lot like so people that like me it
affects me a lot because what Joe told
me that really blew my mind is that your
brain it your your brain is getting
tricked into thinking what you're
reading is your own voice saying it
about yourself so if you're reading a
negative comment that's already your
brain is telling you that that's what
you believe in and that that it's true
yeah you read it out loud in a different
voice you trick yourself and that's what
you know what I actually do now if I do
come across something negative and it
makes me feel in a negative way
now what I've learned to do now that I
know that that evil voice exists in my
head I try to change it so instead so
like that negative part will first come
out because it's just a natural reaction
and then I'll talk to myself and say no
hold on no that that person doesn't know
you they don't know where you're coming
around like you are worthy you're
valuable and you're beautiful and you're
amazing and I just try to really like
like talk to my talk myself look as I
can and then all of a sudden that like
negative feeling in my chest from
reading that negative comment like it
starts to dissipate and I'm like oh my
god this really works like really
talking to yourself positively does
wonders work that thing that Gio
actually sent us in our group chat the
other day there was a video that she
sent and it was I I don't know who was
in the video maybe you guys knew but it
was a guy talking to giving a pep talk
Gary we okay he's Gary Vee okay well
anyway one thing that really stuck for
me was he said people are judging you
off of just a clip of you they saw
they're just they're not seeing the full
picture they're just seeing a clip of
you and painting a whole picture from
that and so that's not fair to let that
opinion affect you and I really thought
about that because I was treating it as
if these people knew my entire essence
and I get really defensive yeah more
just like that's not me that you don't
know me but I don't I can't defend
myself and so it gets frustrating with
the comments but you know like thinking
of it that way and like hey they're only
human their own like we all do it when
we see it's also projection like
something that I've also learned
recently that has helped me a lot is
that every single person on this
lanit has pain that they're dealing with
every single person and so whenever they
lash out against you or like something
that you might take it like you might
get hurt by something that someone says
about you it's first of all its
projection on their own pain and second
of all the reason why you're hurt is
because you believe that thing that
they're saying so you're also projecting
your own pain on yourself and I think so
that has been powerful for me because
then whenever I am talking to someone
and like you know something will come up
where I feel like whoa like would it
what do they mean by that or something
like Mike I started like overanalyzing
whatever conversation just happened in
my evil brain inside of me others
telling me these negative things the
good brain of me like starts telling
myself like no hold on that's not what
they meant or if they did mean that well
look at what their situation is and like
I tried to rationalize what it was that
they said that it actually came from
their own pain if it was something
direct yeah and if it wasn't something
direct at me then it's just like I'm I'm
creating that pain in myself from
whatever it is I'm believing it exactly
uh Jess have you done anything to try
and combat that and raise your
self-esteem now that you're aware of it
and now that you know that like I do
self-deprecating stuff and then I
believe it yeah I mean I'm currently
going through a lot of like self-help
books and also therapy and like self
therapy and journaling type of stuff too
so I never realized that doing the
self-deprecating humor thing was also
damaging myself so that's something that
I think over time I'm gonna want to try
to do less of and I don't think
necessarily it damages everyone who does
it because a lot of people do it but
they don't really feel that bad about
themselves so but in my case I think I'm
doing it because I'm like oh I feel like
a piece of [ __ ] so I'm just gonna like
let you know that I feel like a piece of
[ __ ] and then everyone will laugh but
then you know five minutes later I still
feel like a piece of [ __ ] oh my god it's
not helping my life no it's not doing me
any favors
so I'm I don't have any answers yet like
I don't know what to do yet but I think
a lot of it's really just taking some
time to realize like I'm just living in
my thoughts and like there's a bigger
picture in the world and like why do I
care so like why
my so self-absorbed to let myself feel
bad about myself it's like there's so
much more [ __ ] going on like why am I so
worried about like oh this person said
this thing or that thing or whatever
like I'm it's really just me being
self-absorbed the thing that really
helped me randomly that I don't the
person doesn't even realize I remember
in in seventh grade PE you know it's
like in middle schools when you start
changing in front of other people and
all the girls like people see me naked
the PE teacher said stop being shy about
changing other people care more about
themselves and they care about staring
at you they don't care and what's great
about themselves exactly so I was like
oh [ __ ] that's right and then I think
that really really taught me a lot just
that one line itself that's really cool
how you got all this so early that's
genius
I know so I feel like I've just very
recently gotten a lot of this from
therapy and from just like same thing
like everyone's in their own head and
only cares about their own problems so
yeah and if they like on the fly say
something that hurts your self-esteem or
something it's kind of like now you're
holding on to that and making it real
whereas they forgot about it and they
don't even really think about it the
next time they look at you they probably
forgot they even said that to you I like
you're holding it and you're keeping it
and making a part of yourself and it's
just damaging yeah so you gotta just let
it go on the other spectrum though um I
know that for a while I like I'd have my
self esteem but at one point I got
really arrogant and I know it too
because how I deal with [ __ ] like people
that say things about me is I'm less
wholesome than you guys I'm a dick bag
about it so like if someone were to say
something to me negatively the first
thing in my head is I know you're not
talking me like that when you're like
dude that's five foot two like get off
your [ __ ] booster seat and talk to me
you know like I don't like you have no
right to step to me all the five foot
two men are like in in my mind it's like
you better be [ __ ] perfect to ever
say anything's right just like throwing
stones and in class exactly so that's
one thing but also it's a kind of like a
double-edged sword because I knew that
at one point I got really arrogant and I
have a rule like if two or three or
three people have said the same thing
about me then it might be true and I'm I
need to
look into it so you check yourself I
check myself that's really yeah because
if like if three people told me you know
Jesus kind of [ __ ] arrogant and then I
will sit back me like oh [ __ ] I might be
you know because I'm on this this
[ __ ] like high pedestal like no one
can say [ __ ] to me
but that doesn't leave room for
self-improvement right yeah so I you
know I sit back and I take a look like
am i arrogant do I have the right to
even be that arrogant you know and you
know if there's it was like a it was a
learning process so after a while I'm
like alright I need to kind of like tone
it down a little bit so I do the
self-deprecating humor you know just for
fun but at the same time when I do that
it's also a lot of things that I know
that aren't true like all my Twitter I'm
like oh I'm such a lonely [ __ ] but I
know that I'm not yeah yeah or like I'm
[ __ ] poorly I'm not like like a
little bit less truth - exactly - yeah
so I'm I'm more fueled my self-esteem is
fueled by me being addicted other people
if they ever say anything to me because
I'm not gonna just sit there and take it
you know because I know for damn sure
you have like [ __ ] webbed toes or
something you're [ __ ] geared to you
know fancy [ __ ] but I did have to like
tone it back a little bit and learn not
to be super fireball yeah such a
fireball but the thing is like I spent
my whole life making sure that I didn't
lack in a lot of things I get in like
that people can't say [ __ ] to me cuz my
dad has always told me don't give him a
chance to say any [ __ ] about you right
so if people are like well she's just a
dumb blonde I'm just like well okay
here's why I'm smart or like oh she's
just a go-go dancer it's like alright
well I eat fire too like I do more than
that you know and then one of my
favorite lines that I learned recently
was people are always worried about what
you bring to the table
I brought the [ __ ] table what are you
bringing to me you know yeah I had to
make sure that I am capable and
confident and skilled enough and I
filled everything that I ever wanted to
do to bring my own table to this party
so you make sure to build your table and
make sure it was on - yeah
and like you know like this there's a
there's one point where this girl did
not like me uh-huh because like I pretty
much dimed her out she was cheating
my friend and then so and then I hear
from my friends like well she wants to
get on call with you and talk to you and
then I asked and I told her I was like
well here ask her this first talk to me
about what what are you gonna say about
me what can you possibly say about me
that's negative after [ __ ] you did
and then all sounds like oh she doesn't
wanna talk to you anymore I'm like
exactly I didn't give you [ __ ] to talk
about that's such a good line don't give
them [ __ ] to talk about I mean like yeah
you're gonna make your mistakes whatever
if you do happen to give them [ __ ] to
talk about
own up to it yeah I had a laugh about it
yeah take responsibility learn how to
laugh about it don't do it again
and you know we're all gonna make
mistakes exactly just not beating
yourself up about it which I think I get
in the trap of beating myself up about
every little thing yeah so a couple ways
if you're out there like struggling with
building your self-esteem building your
table let me strong about you no one is
say stop to your inner critic we all
have that voice the evil voice that if
was talking about do that that [ __ ] is
a bastard yeah it did you go yeah yeah
after what after reading the power now
he talked a lot about your ego and then
I named my ego TIFF Oh whenever TIFF was
going off and like [ __ ] sit down you
read the book the artists way no dude
they say that's an exercise in really
yeah it's actually named your inner
critic and like let them go off so you
write like all the things bad about
yourself and like let them rant and so
and eventually they run out of breath
yeah and then you're like okay you feel
like you said everything you need to say
yeah no no that is I mean you're like
this is ridiculous why do i why do I
think any of this [ __ ] in my you know
[Laughter]
have an ego that's there something I'm
gonna be NIC oh so we're all Italian
who's hungry
me me me me me me and what should you do
about it you should order some hello
fresh hello [ __ ] hello fresh oh my god
do they say like that hello hello fresh
hello [ __ ]
hello freshers America's number one meal
kit where you can get easy seasonal
recipes and pre-measured ingredients and
feel like a pro chef that's delivered
right to your the only way I can ID can
cook I try to cook for Joe the only way
it happens is if I got hella fresh it
makes you look good yeah you know what
you're doing same girl I like plating it
just like the little picture well it I
mean we try to make it look as good try
all right
but yeah so you can say goodbye to
endless grocery shopping and you can
also add extra meals to your weekly
order or you could skip your delivery
date in case you're going on vacation
you can also change your delivery days
but in order for you to get $80 off your
very first month of hellofresh you got
to go to hello fresh com slash b tch 80
that's eight zero Tom to me that is
hello fresh calm slash b tch eight zero
for $80 off your first month and these
meals are delicious and they're so easy
to make yes yeah I was thinking as you
guys were talking earlier I was thinking
about you know how you said you were in
gifted programs when you were younger
yeah I've noticed that myself like cuz I
was - yeah I was gonna gifted and
talented programs - and I feel like and
I don't know if this is true but I feel
like there's just kind of a trend
between kids who start out and these
gifted and talented programs when
they're super young and then with a lack
of self esteem later on in life and I'm
wearing wondering if it's because
they're getting so used to like Oh
everything should be easy for me yeah
like if I don't get it right away then
something's wrong with me because I am
gifted and I am talented so if it's not
easy for me then something's wrong yeah
and so I think I went through life only
enjoying when things were easy for me
and then when I when they were hard for
me I just completely avoided it I never
learned how to work through things so I
think not being able to learn how to
work through things and then taking that
into my adult life that's severely
contributed to a low self-esteem and low
confidence - because it's like it's
supposed to just be easy for me like why
aren't why isn't this just easy for me
yeah why don't I get it right away there
are some studies that show that instead
of showing telling your kid like oh my
god you're so smart
you're supposed to say you're such a
hard worker yeah yeah so hard because
when they grow up they're like wait like
they they will think like oh I don't
have to work that hard anymore and then
that leaves failure and they're like
wait what happened like oh yeah oh wow
so for me it was an expectation so now
that they knew I was smart like if I got
anything lower than an A I would get my
ass handed to me and it was oh yeah
she's like really fearful if you set the
bar low enough anything is because my
brother was in all regular classes and
he would could barely get a see yeah and
they were like happy you throwing
parties when he got C's and I was like
what no mom could work that's right
that's what I do when I date to like on
my first date I won't put on as much
makeup and then later on what I really
put it on be like [ __ ] yeah dude see no
expectations now you're surprised and
you're [ __ ] luckiest [ __ ] just along
your lines the way your of what you were
talking about of just kind of being
programmed a certain way so for me I
would get rewarded when I got straight
A's or when like any time I did
something they would be like oh good job
and I felt like I guess subconsciously I
processed that as love and that I only
was worth love when I did something are
you words of affirmation I know I know
I'm actually acts of service and or and
quality time we should do a whole
episode on that yeah but yeah so anyway
I thought gallic so when it got to being
an adult and I didn't feel like I was as
successful as I want it to be or I
wasn't hitting the goals that I had set
for myself I felt like a failure and I
as a failure I felt like I did was
unworthy of love and I just got super
depressed and one of the things that I
brought up in the JK news all girls cast
episode we were talking about self-care
and self-esteem was this really helped
me when I was listening to my therapist
and she said like you're a human being
not a human doing yeah you deserve love
just for being so when you look at a
baby yeah look if you think of a little
baby that baby doesn't have to do
anything for you to give it love that
baby is just being a baby
and you deserve that baby you
she doesn't mean it she's so [ __ ]
much and she has to do this [ __ ] [ __ ]
tyka like when you like a guy and they
don't like you back and so you have to
be like [ __ ] that guy psyche little
piece of [ __ ] you do all day just sit
there stupid I love you yeah I like that
I like that line I've never heard that
before it's really sweet really helped
like turn my brain around because I
really did feel like I had to be
constantly doing in order to accept love
mm-hmm I think mine was a little
different because um I never really got
a whole lot of praise like my parents
weren't super involved in my childhood
at all like they were just kind of at
work or somewhere else or so it was
really the only the expectations I put
up on myself so it's like I should get
these things easy you know you know like
so I'm just comparing myself from that
point forward like if it's if I'm not
getting it easy then I suck like I'm
more than that things I think I'm wrong
yeah yeah I think I'm very like a
big-picture kind of person because one
of the things that I've always told
myself was that I've never actually
failed in anything it's just a work in
progress that's so helpful yeah because
it's like okay so you fail to get this
guy like or you didn't get this guy's
attention or whatever you didn't fail
you're working on progress to the actual
right person you never actually fail
you're just yet that doors being closely
found a way that didn't rels yeah
exactly yeah
so that's just like a you know that's
you learn things in life so there's no
failure until death because everything
is a an ongoing yeah I mean it just may
not end in the way you think it is but
it's still not ending because it's still
going in a different direction exactly
branch if you quit or if you quit or you
sit there and don't do anything like you
didn't get that job okay well that's
because you're making progress towards
the right job for you yeah
and that helped me a lot to get a lot of
stuff like rejection and stuff but yeah
breakups like I remember the ones where
you get dumped it's like man those are
hard to get over because you're like I
really still have feelings for that
person and I felt we were meant to be
but really it's just like that wasn't
the one for you yeah it wasn't the one
exactly and bless your ego gets in way
too like how dare you don't mean yeah oh
yeah power of now and
the other one though awakening the new
earth by Eckhart Tolle those are really
good books for checking your ego and
like melting it so other things you can
do is take a two-minute
self-appreciation break these are this
was really hard for me because I had a
hard time recognizing small milestones
and celebrating like little progress
points because I only could see that I
wasn't hitting the big progress points
and so every day felt like a failure
because I was like well I'm not on a TV
show or I'm not like I didn't book that
audition or whatever it is but there's
all these little things that you're
doing every day that are progressing you
forward that you need to take time to
recognize and like celebrate so Steve
and I have this thing where like
whenever one of us books like a big job
or like not even a big job but just like
gets a gig we take the other one out for
dinner and it used to be that we didn't
have a joint checking account but now
it's like whatever but it did like it
was the symbol that was symbolic of like
hey this is achievement you know because
it's so easy to overlook those and
that's a big thing when it comes to like
depression - I know at one point in my
life I was really depressed and it was
just like well I mean I can't do
anything like I suck whatever like this
is like early on when I was going
through [ __ ] but then I started
realizing that I need to appreciate my
smaller achievements yeah yeah I'm
depressed but hey look out of my bed
yeah I showered today that's you know
and then you have depression that's huge
yeah it's huge or like oh I stepped
outside for like five minutes you know
so yeah they're appreciating all the
little things you can do and then also
like when when I do find myself in like
a bad situation like something didn't go
my way or and my friends who I always
help them to remind yourself like hey
you have a bed to sleep in like even the
most minor thing you have a bed to sleep
in
you're breathing yeah you know clean
water there's like all these like things
that a lot of people don't have exactly
and then like you start thinking about
then you're like oh [ __ ] you know me
yeah it's not that bad yeah I didn't get
this thing but [ __ ] at least I have a
home in a house and water and you know
people that love me and stuff yeah it's
gonna start remembering all the little
things instead of just or making or just
just focusing on such huge things that
you didn't accomplish yeah that's true
and definitely when you're in a state of
depression it's really hard to even see
that you know you have to try really
hard
like yeah I woke up today I'm not dead
yeah yeah it's it's hard I don't know
about you but to-do lists daily to do
this used to give me anxiety cuz if I
didn't get all of them then I like felt
like I failed the day so what I started
doing instead was I'd have like maybe
like a weekly like these are the things
that I need to get done but then at the
end of each day I would just list the
things that I got done rather than
focusing on all the stuff I didn't do I
would just list like I went for a
30-minute run and I you know like kind
of like the gratitude thing but all the
accomplishments I guess like a little
baby achievements that get you somewhere
so then because failures such a huge
weight on me it's like oh look at all
the things that you won at and didn't
fail that today when that help building
your old cheerleader team yeah I wanted
Oh God I'm like I'm like a big like
earlier when they said that was gonna be
on this episode I was afraid that I
wouldn't have anything to put oh no
you're really great because like I told
you I'm like I don't know what Wednesday
because literally the only thing I go by
is I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] what you say
about me or like think of it really do
not give a [ __ ] at all and that's like
that's the most I mean like it's kind of
its kind of healthy but sometimes I
should give [ __ ] you know I taught me
like I said earlier it sucks in the
right place yeah yeah yeah earlier like
I said I check myself sometimes that's
when I give a [ __ ] but most of the time
it's like if you just go through life
without really go [ __ ] oh yeah and by
the way I think that's so healthy like
constructive criticism should be welcome
yeah you know you shouldn't if people
enough people are saying things you
should go okay maybe like I just take
account to what I can take
responsibility for and and start
adjusting and see how you feel about
that that's that's growth that's
improvement but Jess maybe you have this
because you're talking about the the
gate thing and I know you have this tiff
but the perfectionism oh yeah is really
a self-esteem killer like when you when
you're used to being a certain level of
intelligence in school or a certain like
you need things to be a certain way and
then you fail to hit your own mark yeah
that's when you start like really
crumbling self esteem wise so one one
thing that you can really focus on is
just like letting go of perfection
Emin ism and like doing things on
purpose that you know you're gonna fail
at just to like get it out of the way
yeah yeah that's one of the hardest
things I'm currently struggling with
because not only am i perfectionist with
myself but I'm a perfectionist with the
people that I love the most which is
like Casey and Isaac like I and me
yeah and Gina of course it's from the
movie cocoa in tradition like a family
yeah and they can cross a bunch of
people message me afterwards oh my
friend let me someone to live longer
than you then if I put you on my own
friend I was low-key pissed at my family
that I none of this was taught to me and
I'm like oh really I didn't know
anything about the culture yes I don't
know I don't know Thalia sidetrack I
know I'm putting in the old friend to
everybody right now watching put me on
your old friend oh I don't care if I'm
not dead yet just put me there just in
case no well yeah for sure I struggle
with perfectionism and I try to tell
myself like it's okay just loosen up
girl loosen I should name the positive
so there's TIFF Allah and yeah
video game character too so she's a
really dope one sees okay cool then
Danny yeah it's like no I hate fanny is
kicking Adi
I dislike that nickname
but anyway have you guys notice how
[ __ ] up my teeth is yeah yes I get
handed okay because your teeth moves
apparently when you're eating all you
I'm so glad you're getting your teeth
fingers I can't even look at you like
watch your [ __ ] you're beautiful Oh
hallo and therapist was like another
girl I can't help her
only candid can help clear braces that
you can order and they send it to your
house it's really convenient they have
an orthodontist that you speak to or
it's licensed in your state and a create
air they create a treatment plan for you
they create a 3d preview of how your
teeth will look like after your
treatments done so I know I'm gonna look
great afterwards and you have to go to
like a molding process and then after
they approve it and they approve your 3d
preview they create custom clear
aligners and they send them directly to
you there's no hassle of going to an
orthodontist office and candid costs
about 65% less yeah than braces wow
these are expensive yeah they're painful
you can't remove them you can remove and
you can eat with just your regular
braces ugly sometimes like when I was
when I had them I'm like yeah yeah I
can't be 30 years old for braces a
godsend oh my god there's a fetish for
their summer and for every aligner that
is purchased candid donates $25 to smile
trained who brings safe 100% free cleft
lip and palate treatment to children all
around very amazing
so to get straighter brighter teeth in
an average of just six months learn more
at candid co.com slash b tch and use the
code b tch to get $75 off $75 off dollar
US dollar US dollars USD dollars that's
candid co.com slash b tch and then use
the code b tch or $75 elastics that
grill yeah so one thing that really
helped me recently because I got I don't
know if I I didn't plan on talking about
this I guess but recently just a swath
of hate comments like really got to me
and I've been on the internet for a
really long time since like 2007 so 12
years I've liked being like in the
public eye and I've gotten tons of hate
comments but in particular this just
head
the aggressive amount that sighs yeah I
think I tried it yeah you did I was like
going in with a little kid it was just
because it was so like incorrect and I
felt like I couldn't defend myself
because it's like I'd have to talk to
each one individually and there was like
so much and there was a bit of mob
mentality that was coming at me so I got
in kind of a depression because of it
because I just felt defenseless and I
couldn't do anything can't roll out of
your control
yeah and it was out of my control and I
then I went back I remembered this thing
that I learned from a book that I read
by his name's John Kim actually and he's
those by angry therapists on Instagram
but he wrote a book and he has this
chapter about non-negotiables and these
are things that people can't take away
from you they're not negotiable so
whatever I decide like this is who I am
at my core these are my intentions these
are my very--it this is my very being
you can't take that away from me you
can't say like no you're not that and so
one of them is character assassination
like you are not allowed to take
something that you don't even know about
and and strip me of that validity and
and paint me as this evil thing like
that's not allowed to happen at least in
my own mind because what was happening
is that because a mob of people were
saying these very untrue things I was
starting to believe it like how you said
like when you start reading things and
it becomes your own voice and I started
to get in that self loathing type of
like yeah I do suck and yeah I'm and I
am a [ __ ] and I I don't deserve
anything and I don't deserve love and I
started getting like really dark and um
and then I I really had to just use
every [ __ ] exercise I've ever learned
at any self-help book about like pulling
myself out of it and I listed all of my
intentions in for the world and like all
of the things I've been working on and I
am like loyalists [ __ ] I will have
anyone's back that I'm like friends with
I am very funny loving yeah funny I'll
put like smart on there like all the
things that people were saying I'm
and all the stuff I had to combat it and
I had to read that list out loud I have
never done so many [ __ ]
affirmations in my life that I'm not
like an affirmation person but like I
really had to go there and it helped a
lot because I needed a cheerleader in my
corner that was like myself because he
was always there for me but like I
needed me to be there for me yeah and so
I was like lookit this list
no one's allowed to take that from you
yeah and from then on I've just anytime
a comic came up it did not get through
that barrier anymore awesome
yeah created that barrier yeah a big
thing that I've actually noticed
recently my little brother's going
through it actually um parents need to
teach their kids how to take I guess you
can say failure I had to fail
successfully yeah because my little
brother he's currently 18 years old
right and he's like going through those
crazy like teenage hormones and stuff if
something goes wrong he freaks the [ __ ]
out because my dad has always taught and
my dad has always taught us to be really
proud man I think that's where I got it
from - yeah like you have to be proud
you have to be good this yeah well I'm
the best and whatever but he never
taught him how to fail so when things
start going wrong he didn't know what to
do and he freaked the [ __ ] out you know
so like now we're like I'm like slowly
trying to teach him like yeah dad taught
you this thing because dad's like a very
rough around the edges kind of guy but
as a female me and my mom are teaching
like hey it's okay to not be perfect at
something like it's okay for you to not
do this right now and just like not
accomplish this right now and I think a
lot of people don't teach their kids
then it's yeah important like ya have to
teach them like it's not the end of the
world when something goes wrong like
you're not gonna die and that's teach us
I'm like okay it's not the inner world
when someone thinks something terrible
but you've got so many good values as a
child or a piece of [ __ ] yeah I think
it's the book failing forward by John C
Maxwell it's a really good book if you
haven't read it I'm like just a book
reference only non sick boy she's so
smart but yeah they talk about that very
thing I'm pretty sure it's that book
where instead of going around at the
dinner table at family dinners and being
like what did you do today or how
your life good he would ask like would
you fail out today and they celebrated
their failures because it's like that's
where you learn you learn all of your
clears and so failure creates success
and so you have to learn to celebrate
your failures otherwise you're always
going to try to be avoiding them and
you're never gonna grow and learn and
stuff it's so wrong so Timmy what
[ __ ] you suck at today wow you
[ __ ] suck really I can't wait for
your kids are you so sarcastic so funny
we don't you know talking about raising
your kids so that's something I'm
currently learning how to do because
I've already realized that I [ __ ]
Isaac's 11 he's such a sweet like he's
he's really the best but spoken but when
it comes to failure though that's where
I know I [ __ ] up because he takes it
so hard on himself when he whenever he
has a correction on his homework he
beats himself up like crazy and I'm like
damn it I totally did that so I'm now
trying to work with him oh he's about to
start school soon so I'm now trying to
work with him and I've I told I had this
really long talk after we did our arrow
pulling thing I had like an arrow
pulling session with Isaac where I told
him like this is where I think I created
arrows in you and I want to apologize
and perfectionism was one of them and so
he like in that conversation too I was
telling him like you know what I I can't
keep doing this to you because this is
hurting you a lot and this is crippling
you so whenever you make a mistake I am
just gonna let you make mistakes like I
have to learn to let you make mistakes
and you figure it out on your own and
I'm gonna be learning that with you
because I still don't know how to do
that because I'm you know I love my son
I want yeah you'll do that it comes out
of good intention everything good for
him and I don't want to see him fall but
it's so important to see him fall and I
let him fall because then he's gonna
become stronger yeah he's gonna become
much stronger and more independent and
more mature and so I'm like this is
necessary and I and I was talking to him
I'm like I just don't want you to hate
me for this cuz you know I love you no
matter what I'm always gonna be here for
you but you you're gonna have to start
learning how to fail and picking
yourself up because I can't keep holding
you up it's like everybody needs to
recognize that it's like every
relationship like every breakup that you
go through
you learn something that you should do
or should not do what you do what you
don't like and what you're willing to
tolerate you learn with every single
relationship that for like a better word
failed you know and that's how life is
exactly he has to learn how to go
through all these things and then
they'll teach him a lot of things
there's some quote that I read the other
day that I really like and I probably
gonna butcher it but it's just something
like the difference between a master and
the apprentice is that the master failed
way more times and the apprentices even
started or even try to do anything so
like you can't get to the top of where
you want to be without failing a whole
bunch of times and I never for some
reason I missed that in life I thought
like no if I try and I put effort into
it I'm it's just gonna go the way I want
it to yeah so when it didn't it just
completely crushed me yeah crazy I think
how did I miss that
first so many years you're basing what
you know off of your past experiences
and your past experience was like I try
I succeed yeah I succeed and so it's
like I try to fail we what ya know as
soon as I'm thinking like oh maybe maybe
I'm not gonna get this right away like I
don't even put any effort into it at all
so it's just avoidance avoidance
avoidance in life you know then it's
weighing on ya there was a study that I
was reading about and I don't know the
book I can't even reference it but it
was really it was really interesting to
me because of dealing with perfectionism
they took this group and they split it
into two halves and this half of the
group they had to me it was in a
ceramics class and they had to make the
perfect pot so they could only make one
pot but it had to be the perfect pot and
this group had to make as many pots as
they possibly can they had to just make
the most that they've ever made in their
lives and so what they found was this
group spent most of the time speculating
on like okay what's gonna be the perfect
pot what kind of shape should it be it
should be like this should it be this
thin on top and they like really spent a
lot of time into preparing how they were
gonna do their one thing one pot yeah
and this group just went ham and like
started making a bunch of pots because
they just had to get focused on quantity
and what they found was that this group
actually turned out perfect pots by the
end of it like they were turning out
like tons of perfect pots
whereas this group had a mediocre pot
because they only
I'd want it in practice yeah they'd
spent so much time speculating how to
not fail at making it yeah that they
just didn't do that good of a job by the
time they actually did it and I think I
do that in life right now like I think
so hard before I do something that I'm
like I have to figure out all of the
ways that could go wrong I have to
figure out all the ways that I are the
things I have to do to make it go right
and then it just winds up mediocre yeah
like I've done that with my hurts you
too because you're like oh I spent all
that time and it only turned out
mediocre yeah see kids that means do a
lot of plot poorly influencing these
kids so they're nice like self care
things that you guys do now because I
know that's like kind of a new as a
newish concept for me at least cuz it's
growing up it was always like work work
work work work but now it's kind of like
yo you need some self care like I've
actually started going and working out
down just so no yes so it's not
consistent okay Jess oh but at least I
have tried to go and it is really
difficult for me to to because again I'm
afraid of failure as well yeah I'm
trying to okay so I signed up to his new
membership thing it's a class pass where
you can get a whole bunch of if you get
one membership and you could try not to
sponsor but if you want to sponsor oh
yeah yeah hit us up yeah so I've been so
in love with it so I've tried out like
aerial yoga and rave I can't [ __ ] with
that yeah it's really hard but it's
really really fun and and then like I
did a bar class which I've always been
in chocolate bar which is like ballet
yoga Pilates all that stuff right so I I
have booked these classes and got my
butt to these classes when I do booked
them but then when I'm done with that
class I'm like oh I can't wait for the
next one I want to do this next one and
then I start looking at my schedule and
I'm like well tomorrow I have to film
from this
and I'm a morning workout kind of person
I start making all these excuses for
myself where I'm like well I can't do it
that day the next day I can't either and
then the next day and then will I
probably shouldn't so I I'm in this
state feel it before it you mean exactly
that's where I'm at right now in this
moment I'm trying to get out of that and
I'm trying to just be like just say [ __ ]
it and just do it yeah I'm so scared of
booking the the class and because I
prefer working in the morning working
out in the morning I'm not a morning
person so then there's I added layer of
like I'm afraid I'm gonna miss the class
and I'm not gonna wake up and it's just
yeah I'm right there right now so but
you're over trying instead of just just
doing that I'm doing I think and think
and think and think and I shut the idea
down before I could even get to it it's
so funny you're the opposite of me cuz
you're yourself help is going out and
doing things myself help is shutting
everyone out and just having a lot of me
times myself at home by myself doing
fuchal I'm across between YouTube
because I go to the classes myself and
that is like an Aloni time I don't know
anybody there I'm not talking to anyone
I'm not socialising it's just like me
getting to sweat it out or be me yeah I
am cuz I spent so much my life working
in entertainment and nightlife like it
was like I was around crowds all the
time always entertaining always speaking
to people always with friends and stuff
like that that I realized that I have
like a social meter that I need to
recharge yeah like I like I could be the
social butterfly and like doing videos
and dancing stuff like that but my
self-help is at the end of that I go
home and I shut myself out for like a
week and recharge I don't talk to anyone
I don't go anywhere I don't like all I
do is just sit at home play video games
and yet nap three times a day and that's
my self help yeah like a face mask or
something do you might like really do
like my intricate skincare routine so
yeah that's my cell I think it's
whatever makes your stress levels go go
down because I recently found out about
how much stress actually impacts [ __ ]
being your mental your physical health
my dietitian was actually the one that
was like you need to really prioritize
cuz at first I was like yeah self Carol
do it when I have time but now she was
like you need to prioritize at least an
hour a day to yourself that's just like
creative time that has nothing to do
with work that you can't think about
work or anything because I was like kind
of letting
work overrule my life because I wanted
to be productive and that because that's
where I derive love from is
accomplishing things and when she said
that it was causing a lot of the effects
of the SIBO and like the bloating like
it was just amplifying those effects I
was like [ __ ] why I don't want to look
all bloated in my pictures and like I
didn't know that that was contributing
to it so much and like as contributes to
your sleep cycles and cortisol is a
[ __ ] yeah but that cortisol bit it
blocks vitamin absorption it harder for
you to lose weight for sure I'm feeling
that right now because I'm like working
out three times a week with a trainer
and I go by myself two other times a
week and dieting you might be oh wait
like that I can't get rid of like I'm
cutting calories and I'm still not doing
it's a hormone Jess I was there like
like six months ago where I was doing
all these hit workouts and dieting and
stuff and she said that that was
actually causing more stress to my body
and she made me go down to just going on
walks every day and then I lost 15
pounds because I was over working with
my a lot of people have trouble
disciplining themselves yeah I'm gonna
work out but I was actually you and I
are just like well I don't think my
workouts are that hard like they're an
hour of easy workout oh okay but it's
still that I'm just going everyday and
yeah it's helping me mentally - but
that's good it's just like I can't lose
the way it's like my body is still
holding on to it yeah so yeah cortisol
is that it's cordis meditation it's to
protect you in a survival situation so
your brain doesn't know if you're
stressing because a lion is about to eat
you or if because you're just your
schedules a mess and so like it just is
like okay we're gonna shut down this
digestive system we're gonna shut down
this and we're gonna build this up and
so we can store all the fat like shoots
adrenaline like all this yeah and so it
just totally [ __ ] your whole system up
where your body is preparing to be in a
cave for six months or whatever and and
really you're like yeah you don't need
to hold on to this fat did you do this
regulate what your body does when you're
stressed out yeah it's a regulate oh no
or Carter cortisol's like your body's
last digit well I think it releases to
get the hormone yeah and um yeah so when
you're relaxed and you de-stress it
makes the cortisol levels go down
and then your vitamins get absorbed and
your digestive system works a lot of
people are constipated because they're
so like all these things and if you're
not getting good sleep - you're not your
body's not able to like regenerate and
kind of flush out all these toxins and
stuff so it just kind of builds up and
makes you feel more and more sick and
like worse yeah
the opposite happens - for me I sleep
too much sometimes oh my god I feel like
my body is exhausted
yeah shut down I also found that my mind
would go Blake like I would space out in
the middle of sentences like I just
really yeah my brain is look my mind my
brain no yes right now like current TIFF
right now her brain is [ __ ] up tipo is
giving you the wrong no I mean this time
tipo has a point you know we should
really listen to tipo because she has a
point
dude I have insane memory problems right
now
I don't you remember we were at the spa
and then in the middle of a sentence I
freaking up oh yeah I forgot what the
[ __ ] we were laughing at yeah and that
makes your self-esteem right yeah and
then tipples like you see you dumb [ __ ]
like it's not a fault
yeah really not yes it's so many
environment oh and she also said that
there was environmental stress since we
live in LA the air quality is not good
here and so our bodies just even
processing that air is like a huge
stress on our body so you get physical
stress mental stress from work and then
environmental stress and that's just so
much stress that your body is like I
don't know what to do I'm gonna block
everything and shut it down yeah so
self-care very important she's told me
to stop thinking of it as self-care time
and start thinking of it as time that
I'm working on my health actively you're
still being productive exactly even to
that yes cuz I had to rewire my brain
because I felt like it was nothing time
I'm like I could be doing so many things
right now or just doing things that you
just simply enjoy oh yeah like anything
cuz like for instance I like napping and
before like yeah that's a waste of time
like and I look firm believer
of doing things that you enjoy is never
a waste of time that's so true yeah
you're only on this earth for such a
miniscule amount of time in the grand
scheme of things that like yo we gotta
take time that were you actually enjoy
your life you know it can't all be
working stressed you don't know one of
the best things I've ever heard to make
you not give a [ __ ] about what people
think about you yeah um it only takes
like three generations to forget you
after you die
oh [ __ ] people only one like yeah
exactly didn't have kids or something in
their ass so take it down you're gonna
be alone and nobody loves you you're no
one's a friend oh don't go [ __ ] they
never printed out a picture you know and
in the grand scheme of things all that
matters is that you enjoyed your life
and you did no harm yeah I feel like
Steve has a good point and I think you
brought this up earlier about like only
letting that small circle of people
affect you like yes you if one of you
guys told me like yo Gina you're kind of
being a [ __ ] and need to chill I'll
listen to you yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] II and if
you read the books that'll are not
giving a [ __ ] oh yeah everything is
[ __ ] a book about hope yeah that one
yeah and then I love how he's talking
about your emotional brain and then the
logic yes that's such that was so gay I
was like oh my god can you explain cuz
yeah so everyone could ink that so
there's two two brains that you have you
have your emotional brain and your
logical brain and everyone thinks that
they're mostly a logical brain and then
their emotions come in and try to [ __ ]
[ __ ] up so they're logical brains in the
driver's seat and the emotional brain is
in the passenger seat being like I don't
know we should go that way or that way
like your heart in your mind yeah yeah
but actually you're were mostly
emotional creatures our emotional brains
in the driver's seat and the logic brain
you're supposed to suggest things to the
emotional brain to get it to go the way
you want instead of trying to logically
convince it to do certain things you
have to speak the same language as your
in order to get it to go the way you
want so if you want to make a change in
yourself and you're feeling like you
suck at giving public speeches or
whatever you suck at that
that's your emotions being like oh my
god I said um instead of your logic
brain being like well you don't suck
because we studied yeah whatever and
giving it lots of bullet points your
emotional brain doesn't like register
that so it needs to be like any to hear
things like hey you're really good at
this because remember when you felt good
when you gave this one speech or
whatever it's like you need to feed it
emotional things and so yeah yeah cuz I
heard all that and it totally felt like
oh that makes so much sense but then the
last part which is how does the logical
brain talk to the emotional brain that's
the part where I'm like wait how do you
do that again yeah it's something I need
to reread it cuz I don't I might have
watched some of it but you should read
that book yeah yeah we need a book list
from you on our website yeah check out
our website go to our website plug yeah
we're gonna keys corner so you can see
what she like and all my wine my wine
pairings with her cats this book with
this cat with this I would love that
mine is just a picture of a middle
finger well thank you guys so much for
listening I hope that was a little bit
helpful I hope that makes you feel like
you're not alone in the world
love yourself struggling with this
except for Gina you go at the door give
it a name let the critic talk and say
all it needs to say and then say goodbye
to it if you haven't yet would you
please check out our hey [ __ ]
highlights channel a link is in the
description and thanks again to our
wonderful sponsors door - hello fresh
and candid to get five dollars off your
first order of $15 or more download the
door - app and enter promo code hey girl
H ey GI RL for $80 off your first month
of hello fresh go - hello fresh com
b tch 80 and enter b TCH 8-0 get
straighter brighter teeth in an average
of six months
learn more at candid co.com slash b tch
and use code b tch to get $75 off see
you all next week go check out that
highlights channel if you guys are
wondering about my face right now and
stuff because of our sponsors it's
because I just noticed that Gio's
wearing Crocs and I'm gonna kill her